bonjour raymond granville new moon le
temps il bondit aux auditeurs et
auditrices de martinique première porte
parole de l'intersyndicale du btp porte
parole des trois principales centrales
du secteur que sont la ftc cgtm fsm là
c'est ce thème et si que la cgtr btp
raymond qu'en ville
vous aviez annoncé une grève ce matin
sur la question notamment des salaires
sauf que manifestement vous avez du mal
à mobiliser vos troupes
non vous savez que l'is larié tutor
discutant avec eux ici où les chantiers
nous avons fait des assemblées générales
nous avons pris les moyens qu'il fallait
à savoir deux semaines de réparation des
mouvements il nous avons constaté qu'il
y avait beaucoup puissions fait par les
employeurs sur la somme de ses salariés
de que nous avons aussi dit que nous
manquons encore de dimona que pour vous
voir ce que fait cette grève que nous
souhaitons dans le btp pour arracher les
points de revendication c'est que la
situation actuelle ne gêne pas tant que
cela au niveau des salariés
aïe aïe je dis moi donc je peux vous
dire que depuis 2015 nous avons signé
une dernière augmentation 6 2 le btp
aussi bien pour les ouvriers du brésil
elisa poyaud parle de crise mme la prise
de ne pas les salariés qui l'accueillait
ils la subissent de que l'on reviendra
sur la situation du secteur
comment expliquer qu avant-hier samedi
matin vous soyez si peu nombreux au
point de reporter cette manifestation
non nous avons fait comme jeudi des
assemblées générales sur les chantiers
et je vous répète que les salariés de
que subissent une pression de nos
employeurs ils nous on n'a que
difficilement qui seront prises en a que
ce lundi dans le mouvement de grève
donc nous avons fait une assemblée
générale samedi matin à ut autres entre
les besoins syndicats donc effectivement
nous avons constaté que carbo au nombre
de salariés de la branche qu'il n'avait
pas répondu favorablement et c'était
difficile le parti en guerre un chiffre
raymond granville aux chiffres vous
demander une augmentation de 2%
il ya quelques temps vous demandez 3%
dans un secteur en crise
secteur sinistré vous l'avez dit où il
n'y a plus de chantier alors comment
peut-on demander une telle augmentation
lorsqu'il ya pas de rentrées d'argent
pour pour ceux qui vous emploie
mais écoutez là ce soir les propos de
chrétiennes les syndicats d'employeurs
mais nous savons que il y a quand même
plus de 5000 salariés de la branche btp
relativité
ici cela il faut bien que qu'ils ont un
salaire convenable
donc il ya donc une cuisse est mêlé
seriez doivent être revalorisées chaque
année entre 30 et 35 % de baisse
d'activité depuis 2008 selon certains
entrepreneurs
ah oui bon je vous répète que dans le
btp il y a quand même des grosses
entreprises et à des moyennes il y a
aussi les artisans et vous avez passé au
potage dernièrement où on disait que
c'était les syndicats des petites
entreprises
évitez donc eu aucune ou d'un cas deux
élections maintenant tous et ortiz à
tous ses employés
toutes ces grosses sociétés ont un
certain nombre d'effectifs de salariés
et eux il faut ou valoriser le pouvoir
d'achat est cueilli l'argent avec
l'argent de que font donc gagné 6,7 les
salariés passe il faut bien savoir que
dans la société en général ce sont les
salariés qui apporte le profit d'un que
poussé entreprises de que nous
souhaitons simplement que comme je le
dis depuis juin 2015
nous avons signé notre dernier
plateforme doivent cacher sous la
houlette salaires donc cela fait
pratiquement plus de deux ans et demi il
est hors de question que nous les se
terminer l'année 2016 sans que les
employeurs grippe on va voir comment
nous avons alors récemment notamment
avant les grandes vacances vous
dénonciez ce corps patronale c'est
patrons qu'ils savaient faire ce qu'ils
savaient faire ce qu'il devait faire
pour obtenir des subventions des crédits
d'impôt auprès des instances
gouvernementales
dénoncer des patrons qui savent se bat
pour défendre leurs intérêts absolument
j'ai dû appeler que je je suis quand
même recensé dikalo niveau de la cgt m
il nous avons toujours dit que les
entreprises quand ils savent ali que ce
soit au niveau de l'état que ce soit au
niveau des institutions réclamé 10 ou
dont ils savent très bien ils ont obtenu
de pas mal de deux innovations au niveau
de nos charges l'embauchent ne suffit
pas il nous constatons que concernant
les salaires ne bougent pas non plus
mais ils sont largement est tout autre
de plus obtenu de l'argent mais c'est un
jeu n'est pas redistribué
vous êtes quand même au courant qu'il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises du btp qui sont
devant les tribunaux qui sont
redressement judiciaire qui sont
liquidés oui je suis quand même me donne
beaucoup ne put la situation que de la
broche
mais simplement il ya quand même une
situation que nous vivons nous déplorons
mais si les entreprises qui en liquide
et nos sociétés on les voit redémarrer
sous un autre nom ici puis poussèrent
que nous avons donc au mois de début
d'année nous avons signé un accord quand
même avec la diète concernant le travail
contestait ce qu'on appelle plus
normalement la lutte contre le travail
illégal il s'affirmait comme d'avoir un
sujet des effectifs sur le chantier pour
pouvoir donc quand même savoir qui
travaille qui est à sony music du social
son inscription à pepsico gpu de type et
et ça permet quand même de lutter contre
les salariés il s'agit là vous de façon
efficace de manière efficace si la diète
fils au travail parce que c'est tout ça
qui plombe la branche ce n'est pas le
cas vous ne comptez pas du goût c'est le
cas puisque ces documents qui a été
signé en début d'année et nous
constatons que pas mal de sociétés de
que travaille de manière donc pas trop
des gal et que ça permet donc manque à
gagner il sut tout coller ses salariés
là ne sont pas inscrits à cg c'est c'est
le problème le retrouve pour leur
retraite quand il faut faire le dos rond
et qu on constate qu'il n'a pas été donc
inscrit dans que paulo cotisations
les patrons du du bâtiment et travaux
publics se sont retrouvés à plusieurs
reprises les patrons qui sera de la
réunion de la guyane de la guadeloupe et
de la martinique au point de taper du
poing sur la table et pour est éventré
et vente ul mans protester contre ce ce
manque de commandes publiques est-ce que
vous auriez l'idée vos syndicats de
salariés d'aller à compagnie de ses
patrons du secteur pour demander que les
choses bougent au niveau politique mais
ce bulletin je peux vous dit que et si
vous appelez un 2012 nous avons fait une
dimanche au fait sens à savoir que nous
avons fui donc une table ronde avec les
responsables de l'époque c'est la
situation du btp il bien entendu tout le
monde et après tu peux dire que
contester le fait que nous avons fait
cette démarche commune avec les
employeurs du btp mais en réalité c'est
ce que c'est en ville personne
s'apaisent quand même dans le jeu oui
nous sommes parfaitement d'accord ils
conscients de la situation
mais cette nuisance et qu' il y à une
paix d'activité ils nous trouvent faits
et donne obligation c'est exactement ça
ne suit quoi nous étions que en
martinique je suppose en guadeloupe et
en guyane qu'il y a quand même des
bâtiments publics nous trois modes aussi
il faut reconstruire les écoles par atis
mais il ya des hôpitaux ne sont pas en
état un logement social il ya le jeu
social et tout particulièrement que nous
avons commenté nic il y a les trois
sociétés depuis deux saisons c'est celle
que ce soit la sn hlm la cimr et aux
hommes ces trois sociétés sont jaunes
d'oeuf et la spéculation
alors pourquoi ne pas y aller avec les
syndicats de patrons devant les sièges
des conseils d'admnistration de ces
sociétés de 2,2 de loyer modéré et
justement nous dans les têtes et les
gars du btp nous avons prévu de faire
notre démarche est pareillement pourquoi
parce que je vous ai dit que le non
aboutissement du travail fait de ce sens
en 2012 ne compte pas recommencer deux
fois la même chose qu'eux
dans notre champ d'action nous avons
prévu non seulement les trois sociétés
d'achille m il ya là des ailes parce que
il faut savoir aussi que tout le réseau
d'où du sud et martinique je suppose en
général et à offrir il y à pas mal de
travaux qui doivent fait donc il ya un
manque de volonté politique selon vous
il y a un champ wass au niveau des
politiques
il y avait aussi l'état qui doit quand
même faire son travail et que nous
concertons ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent pas mal de charger en tout
simplement s'esquisse ici pour concerne
donc le
le résoudre vous savez qu'on parle
effectivement autour des politiques de
faire seul horizon
le disque dur unique mais concernant les
canalisations
tout le monde sait qu'elle s'oppose et
tout le monde sait qu'il ya de l'argent
de l'europe qu'il pourrait représenter 2
grosso niche dont il a besoin au
chantier long dans le temps on a déjà
lancé dans que c'est une des pistes et
je suis sûr que tout la somme de ces
travaux là les écoles qui ne sont pas un
homme parasismiques les collèges à
refaire les lycées tout ça permet de
relancer l'activité
et bien entendu le logement social si
véritablement à 6,3 ce c'était la
médiumnité le paquet je suis sûr que la
martinique le pouvoir de l'activité pour
ses salariés alors la grève qui est
reporté pour l'instant là c'est un
rapport de force savez j'ai rencontré
quelques patrons 7 au cours du week-end
me dise pas les travail panier là j'en
fais la grève concerne nous baigner ap
pièce jeûne et travail vous dit quoi
puisqu'il ya pas de chantier non ce
n'est pas notre vision c'est la vision
de certains patrons nous disons
simplement que effectivement les
salariés nous sommes conscients de leur
réalité
mais en même temps nous subissons la
crise au niveau de notre porte-monnaie
donc que nous subissons toutes les
augmentations t soit de loyer de
transport donc nous disons c'est
vraiment que la proposition qui a été
faite de robes des et les salaires de 2
nous avons demandé 3 % des 100 dur nous
avons demandé de ne pas nous attirons
0,5
voilà et eux ils disaient au sec mais je
pense que c'est une mauvaise volonté
d'un certain nombre d'entre eux et que
bien entendu il y en a certains qui
comprennent effectivement notre
obligation de nous et nous souhaitons
simplement il ya la diète kid disponible
pour une petite salle pour les
négociations
nous souhaitons simplement qu'il puisse
nous donner que les éléments de notre
fabrication pour qu'on puisse se
comprendre que c'est exactement que le
fruit de travail pour nous les séries du
btp merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
aurait mon grand fils on rappelle que
vous êtes le porte parole de
l'intersyndicale du bâtiment et travaux
publics btp bonne journée
mais si muzio tonneau certitude d'avoir
prêté attention